i really wanted to review new megan fox
and mgk content from the british gq
cover that they did because i think it's
been a long time since we've actually
found content that's actually correct
actually cringe okay at this level okay
and i think this truly is perfect did
you say he's saying yeah but i don't
know anything about it you haven't seen
this no
i only know the quote about i am weed
yeah can we can we read that okay here
we go let's put dramatic lighting on
this is megan fox i just remember this
tall blonde
ghostly creature
and i looked up and i was like
you smell like weed
[Music]
he looked down at me
and he was like
i am weed
then i swear to god he disappeared like
a ninja in a smoke bomb
yeah that's um
to say i mean to say i am weed
and
anything else happened but the girl just
being like okay and leaving is insane to
me this is just peak high school
what a strange way to greet someone
you smell like weed
[ __ ] i am weed and why weed yeah
you could have picked anything else this
also could have been a scene in
mid-summer
what do you mean just one of the people
at the camp all [ __ ] up
this girl [ __ ] up on shrooms and duke
comes close she's like you smell like
weed he's like i am weed
we all are weed
i just think like you know anything
would have been cooler nice shirt i am
shirts
that's cooler than this also like the
his [ __ ] hair in this
like
i don't think
that straight dudes ever wore extensions
are those extensions i can't yes dude he
has short hair oh okay doesn't he
i mean at the vmas did he not have short
hair we can go back to regular lighting
candice we don't have to be
adding a lot of drama
it felt dramatic
this isn't cool
i am shirts i am wheat is also kind of a
classic high thing to say
i am
you smell like weed
i am weed then
you are a girl
the social anxiety is what made him
disappear yeah exactly
i am weed
oh [ __ ]
um and then he realizes [ __ ] megan
fox it's like holy [ __ ] i loved you in
transformers by the way
bye
bye
i am weed
bye
they're perfect for each other they're
perfect wait there's another one
there's another i think she wrote it as
her instagram caption they remind me of
like a couple in high school that got
tattoos first
you know like oh yeah like their parents
got them tattoos first yep they live in
huntington beach 100
and then they every every monday they
come back and they're like
ugh
mean
i don't even know what the machine gun
kelly's real name is
um
kelly yeah me and kelly went dirt bike
riding this weekend with his family it
was so much fun have you ever ridden a
two-stroke
what
he was so high it was so crazy you know
like it's just that yep
100
his real name is coulson coulson oh
perfect coulson right okay yeah
he looks like a colson
more like coleslaw
got him
all right machine gun coleslaw
you mean more like
coleslaw kelly nice dude
are you high by the way i am weak
all right so this is uh this is her
instagram caption right just that was
her quote before now this is directly
from her fingers
yeah the tale of two outcasts
first of all just right off the bat i
mean you couldn't be
more mainstream and you couldn't be less
outcasted that's what i'm saying
how are either of them outcasted
they're not at all
i mean both of them like no no no no
hate to them right no
they're just they're not outcasts at all
she's like the hottest girl in the world
he's like doing the most popular form of
music from the last 20 years yeah how
are they outcasts yeah i don't know
the tale of two outcasts and starcraft
star-crossed lovers caught in the throes
of a
torrid
solar flare of a romance
featuring feverish obsession romance is
an album addictions
is it this is a tracklist
no it's not
i'm joking i'm saying that so she's
described this [ __ ] as an album dude
it's lots of blood
featuring feverish obsession guns
addiction shamans lots of blood general
mayhem therapy
tantric night terrors
binding rituals chakra sound baths
psychedelic hallucinations organic
smoothies and the kind of sex that would
make lucifer a clutch's rosary
organic smoothies holy [ __ ] you're
pretty healthy in the middle of all that
seriously tantric night terrors general
mayhem lots of blood organic smoothies
razzmatazz
jamba juice
kale salad kind of sex that would make
lucifer
clutch his rosary what are they doing
down they'll be like killing babies
seriously are you sacrificing
literal humans yeah so full out like a
nine like a fresh baby and just stab it
clean in the face
even the devil's like hey hey yeah
what the [ __ ] yeah dude this is [ __ ]
dude i'm i'm about to clutch my rosary
real quick this is messed up the devil
goes to church they're like
satan he's like listen
i just watched those two outcasts go at
it let me tell you
they are two star-crossed lovers caught
in a torrid solar flare
matter of fact
bring my boy down here and jesus comes
down he's like satan what the [ __ ] are
you doing this is what are you doing in
my house he's like ah just talk to me
man have you ever had a tantric night
terror before
oh you saw mgk yep ah
so much blood okay come on so much blood
hold the rosary let's do this together
adrenochrome yeah
eating baby foreskin to be younger
stem cells adrenochrome
[Laughter]
harvesting blood from young teenagers
killing poor people
just like what's up general mayhem like
do you just go to their house and
they're just like have chainsaws on
ropes and they're just swinging them
around
they [ __ ] talk like they're like
world of warcraft characters this is
insane also addiction
do you guys need to talk to somebody
yeah like addiction is definitely not
like sexy
that's a dark ass place man i'm assuming
it means like addicted to each other but
oh that also would be kind of funny
right yeah guns shamans general mayhem
crippling meth addiction therapy a
seriously unhealthy reliance on opioids
consistently burning the oven
blown up yogurt in the microwave
super mundane [ __ ]
can't find batteries for the tv remote
hard to turn the volume down on the tv
you